if you are on Instagram all of you are
on Tick Tock all day long all of you
listen to city girls and Meg the
stallion and listen to cardi B and you
worship these like Kim Kardashian type
girls who are just professional hoes and
you thought that those are high value
women but really all of them are just
bad wives and you don't really know
what's going to make a good wife friend
anymore what's going to make a good
feminine woman anymore because that's
seen as oppressive and feminism has done
that and has brainwashed all of you what
do you believe and then became more
feminine and as a result women became
more massive thank you they're trying to
feminize men and masculinize women this
girls are dressed like bimbos sorry to
judge but I can't wait to hear what how
they defend this go ahead the main
antagonist I do this for me she's really
pretty because what feminism basically
did was tell women that men and women
are the same or not and hanging out huh
dress over there but she said something
along we can both be CEOs well that's
the mindset that many modern day women
have that is not true you can't you
can't you can't you cannot have two
bosses it doesn't work that way so you
had a millionaire and you do lashes
but like no I'm just saying I'm just
saying like it's not true no but she's
she's telling you that she tried to be
masculine
financially baby girl that's what she's
saying she's saying like she tried to be
asking her to [ __ ] her up
with my fiance
all right I'll see if I can uh convince
Sonny fast to do that I'll look into it
I'd love that I would love it you know
what that is
I mean like the church show I don't know
CEOs and they could be a good ass place
well I mean I mean
I think the fact that you think that you
and your man are equal tells speaks
volumes that we don't even necessarily
need to go into because when a woman is
with a man that she truly admires loves
and respects she understands that she is
not the same as her man I would argue
most women don't look for an equal they
look for a superior in your case you
don't have a superior which is why
you're able to kind of do the things
that you do should I bring girls on to
react with me that'd be that'd be lit
are we getting these girls I'll find
them I have my I have my career
dumpster or the apartment complex where
are we getting these girls shoot I do my
things you know I got my peoples shoot
shoot a couple messages I will do this I
will sit around this table with us at
the head and you find some of your girls
to sit on that side and I'll find some
of my girls to sit on this side and
we'll see we'll see how that goes let's
do that I'm dead serious come on you
know who I'm sitting on to say Elaine
and Lorraine let's get let's get the
conversation going see what you bring to
the table and who wins dumpster dive and
figure out you know what too I can see
you nodding alongside you know that your
guys I can't watch
which allows you to kind of get away
with some of the things you do okay
let's do the things that you're doing no
so he doesn't have a choice because you
wear the pants so he's insecure and I
wear the pants if I keep going yes and
have it only filmed yes and post on my
Instagram yes oh my God so your
girlfriend can have an Instagram
but what I'm saying is that if you're in
a serious relationship with a guy and
you post provocative photos of yourself
advertising yourself that is
disrespectful to the man and most men
would not prefer that putting a giant
for sale sign on your phone yeah with
their main chick at least
I think I know some ways but I think
it's far more I have a post for me the
line for women is like it you know like
there's so much more for us to reveal
that you know if a man is just like
posting gym picks like yeah there are
going to be some some bimbos around even
if he's got a wedding ring on who are
like oh my God pay attention to me but
for women it's like they just get
bombarded right attention my attention
and so if you're doing that when you are
married or in a relationship it's really
disrespectful it is because you're
getting mad I think everybody has to be
careful about being not being
disrespectful and being an attention
Hound because I know men who get all
dressed up and you do that like
mysterious look in the camera for their
for their Instagram and try to look all
sexy when they're in a relationship and
they are also thirsty for attention what
you want about I was just I was just
talking about this with my friends the
other day there's some girl on Snapchat
that I have who has a boyfriend now and
she's still posting pics on her stories
with her who has in it and I'm like
that's just weird straight up you know
posting that for hundreds of people to
see thirsty yeah with an Instagram that
was like calm like PG to be honest you
want to know what guys like to hear from
when they talk to girls I'll tell you
guys in the game right now I like to
hear things like I don't travel I've
never been here before oh um my
Instagram
verbatim yes it's like it's exactly like
we could pull up the I wish we had the
thing to pull up the clip of saying the
exact same thing I've been to here and
I've been to there and I loved when I
saw this my favorite place is this that
uh when you sit with a dude on a first
date and tell him how many places you've
been all he's thinking is
you know I'm gonna deactivate it or they
don't even have one or they don't have a
social media Presence at all they like
men prefer especially guys that have
status girls that have zero status and
aren't out there he's saying prefer
that's not saying like that's like
that's what he requires he's saying
that's what he prefers what he prefers
so the guy Michael says wedding rings on
men is attractive for women for some for
some women I have to tell you if I see a
wedding ring on a man he might as well
have leprosy because first of all I have
more Integrity than to be with a married
man second of all I have too much value
for myself to be somebody's side dish
some women see it and they feel like
it's a conquest or they feel you know
this extra they feel extra good that
they can get the attention for steal the
attention from another woman no not all
of us are like that sorry news flash
guys don't want girls that are out and
about and have status like women like in
men you guys find that attractive
because when a guy's out and about
whatever shows social status it shows
pre-selection is so social proof but for
a man a man doesn't need to verify a
woman social proof to be attracted to
her that's the key difference if I find
a girl attractive at the club I think
she's attractive I don't give a [ __ ]
what my friends think if you find a guy
at the club and you think he's
attractive you're still going to run it
by your girlfriends and see what they
think right women that's why I always
say women are not independent thinkers
when it comes to mate selection at all
I know so many women that Bradley my own
years myself and other friends the whole
group of friends around them is going
this guy sucks get away from him oh
that's a good point
[Music]
sweet yeah no I wonder what his face
he's dead dead wrong honestly wrong I
also know that there's plenty of times
where a girl likes a guy and then their
friends start talking [ __ ] about him and
then they drop them like it goes both
ways so I don't know I don't know
vacation from other uh other women I
disagree yeah
when you go to the club where do you go
when I go to the club where do I go
where are you sitting at the club when
you're at the club at a table okay hold
on stop stop what are you sitting at the
table with with my girls with your girls
yeah I pray for that table oh
you go to the club and you pay for the
club every single time you go there with
your own section
let's keep it a thousand kind of feel
like I don't even go to the club that
much
so one time girls go to the club you're
going to nightclub where are all the
women concentrated in the VIP yeah a
minority of men a majority of women
so you can say what you want to say but
women are attracted to men that have
social proof and have options and can
and act on that's true but that's not
what his other point that that has
nothing to do with his other point his
other point was girls need uh validation
from other girls in order to like a guy
they said they disagree and now he I
think he's saying that women should
change the subject women take their
input from their friends on their
Partners more than guys I think that was
more of his point that I could be
mistaken because obviously there are
exceptions I guess I know what you're
I'm not talking exceptions I'm talking
majority a lot of uh yeah when there's a
[ __ ] guy and a girl's into him she has
got hooks she's in Hook Line and Sinker
there's no talking her out of it in the
sections because it's a social status
thing women need to see that someone's
wearing so when you're out and about
right and it is an attractive woman
you're like oh my God I'm gonna go and
talk to her and yeah
I don't
know did you not just hear anything I
just said
pumpkin status revoked for the rest of
the night no application from their own
gender to find a woman attract the
pumpkin right now can you not hear that
no but I'm saying like if you find out
that she is a CEO boss [ __ ] that's
gonna turn you off you're gonna be like
damn she's a man
here's the thing her job doesn't matter
are you saying boss [ __ ] don't just
make me instantly not talk to you
because the romanisms and how she acts
yeah I was gonna say like even though
like you guys saying oh I can be
feminine and I can be a CEO like it's
really unrealistic because yes you're
going to be like okay you bring the
feminine energy home say that but as
soon as he gets on your nerve as soon as
you get mad that masculine is going to
pop out eventually there's no way that
you can run from it you're making sure
you you separate it from oh I'm only
masculine at home but I bring my
feminine energy oh I'm only masculine at
my job but I bring my feminine energy at
home that's only when he's doing exactly
what he needs to do when he's the
perfect in your eyes when he's not
rocking your bowl as soon as he doesn't
take out the trash in time as soon as he
doesn't take the dog on a walk as soon
because they ask you to do something and
a minute later if it's not being done
[ __ ] they're out the door that's not
me that's not me you know that yep I
know but later it's not being done I'm
like okay
[Music]
you can play the game a little bit which
is why we tell guys about a girl for a
year like did you date her for a year
and you know so you can see all the
sides because girls will be chameleons
and act like a feminine submissive woman
to get the ringer
oh so will you everybody everybody shows
their best in the beginning nobody shows
up laying out all their ugly cards on
the first date he acts like yeah the men
act great I've dated guys like for three
months and I'm like this is like God
Prince Charming and then all of a sudden
like can you speak up you want to be a
little more quiet they can hear me every
time in other videos when you've said
that you can hear perfectly and I'm fine
I can barely [ __ ] hear it maybe I'm
going down that's because you got those
giant stupid headphones well then you're
talking to me here listen stop picking
on me and leave me alone all right what
were you saying apparently nothing
important enough because I got
interrupted did you forget what you were
saying I didn't forget but I'm done
saying it go ahead just say it carry on
what the [ __ ] man
but you need to bet them for a long
period of time to see where they really
stand and see if they're the real deal
and yes that the reason why I say that
is exactly what she said girls will play
the game or whatever but going back to
what you said about us so I've been
dated guys three months he's Prince
Charming three months in one week one
[ __ ] horn pops out you know another
month goes by another horn pops out next
thing you know he's got red [ __ ]
swirly eyes and he's the devil and you
know what so everybody plays that game
we have to date you for a year or two or
three before we know who you really are
and there's a lot of check boxes that
you need to check you gotta travel
together you gotta introduce the family
you gotta have a fight and see how they
handle it so they curse you out and call
you names or do they you know have a
conversation damn Berlin I'm taking a
required gender Rose class where we are
being taught about patriarchy and toxic
masculinity I've expressed disagreement
but already saw my grade affected what
should I do if you care about your
grades write an anti-male paper and just
get through the [ __ ] thing you're not
you're not changing any Minds there
you're not low-key though I think it's
pretty pimp if you stay if you stay
strong no no get your a because you're
paying it probably six seven eight
thousand dollars for it get your a and
then after you have your a pimp out no
[ __ ] these people you're not changing
any Minds there no I I disagree I'd say
I'd say stay strong brother I used to be
that way and I used to open my mouth and
you know
you gotta pick
s gonna you know stand out and unless
your teacher's a straight [ __ ] I
mean completely it is yeah I guess
you're right I I would always speak my
mind in class and teachers with me would
be pretty like conversational like if I
was really yeah I mean I guess in my
English class he was he would go on
about gender and sex it's a different
thing and I'd be like bro you're being
for real right now in like 10th grade
I'd be like dude in the ninth grade I
got kicked out of religious classes
because I had a religion class because I
had a fight with Mr McBride because he
said animals don't have souls and I told
him about my dogs and how the
relationship I had with my dogs and I
could look in their eyes and I could
tell they had a soul and he said no and
I just went after it and after and after
it and I got kicked out yeah I think
she's just too far away from the mic
listen
everybody leave me alone am I deaf yeah
maybe uh maybe Mr Fitzgerald he's
getting roasted in chat who's Mr
Fitzgerald the CEO boss [ __ ] no I have
the mic no leave it in the middle your
title that turns the guy off it's the
mannerisms
when you're a go-getter and you make a
lot of money it comes with inherent
traits if you look at millionaires
there's Universal traits that
millionaires have okay they're tenacious
they work hard they work long hours
non-agreeable these are all personality
traits that are attributed to higher
what I'm saying is that when a woman is
a high earner I know for a fact she has
these traits and these traits are not
attractive to men simple
is that your knitting needle fatty for
real no cut all right guys quick
reminder my University drops within two
weeks yeah what where
anxiously waiting
first chapter coming out I have an
announcement coming soon I have a I have
a big announcement coming soon Times
Square announcement coming soon really
in the Discord or can we do it here no I
mean I was just gonna post it on my
Instagram oh that good I have to go to
the city later this week I should start
following you on Insta huh you don't
follow me on Instagram it was tagging me
and [ __ ]
gone
[Music]